this video is brought to you by world of
tanks
what's up wisecrack michael here to talk
about the single
cinematic bright spot of 2020
christopher nolan's blockbuster film
tenet now tenet has everything we've
come to love in a nolan film deep
characterization
i'm the protagonist check riveting
action scenes i think that looks
vegetarian i think they both look
vegetarian
check and a mind-blowing premise that
will make you rethink everything you
you know what i can't do this anymore i
can't it's
it's not even funny the truth is is the
tenet is bad
like really bad look we're huge nolan
fans and we tried
and to everyone defending this film
online i really hope it works out for
you
while plenty of critics have picked
apart the film and its nonsensical plot
we think the real problem is a bit more
structural specifically the real reason
tenant fails has less to do with the
confusing mechanics of how a bullet
moves backwards in time
don't try to understand it feel it
well okay actually that is part of it
but rather the bigger problem is that
the film's complexity dooms it to fail
at some very basic and
tenets of screenwriting so join me for
this wisecrack edition on tenet what
went wrong
also spoilers ahead for tenet inception
and the prestige
and before we continue i want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor world
of tanks world of tanks is a
free-to-play mmo that you can play on pc
with over 100 million players worldwide
you'll be able to roll out over 40
battle arenas and command over 550 tanks
whether you ambush your opponents of
sneaky tactics or hang back and take
them out from afar you'll be able to
devise a plan to destroy your
competition if you've never played
before
now is the perfect time to hop in on the
game since world of tanks is
collaborating with gi joe
right now you can purchase the gi joe
breakthrough tank style and the cobra
battle operation assault tank style both
are designed to replicate the classic gi
joe toys tanks lineup if you use the
invite code gi joe 21
and complete the gi joe missions you'll
receive two free emblems
you can then use the gi joe and cobra
emblems to decorate your tank when
activating the mission each user will be
awarded with the emblems and after
collecting 15
tokens you'll be gifted an additional
five to fully outfit the tank
download world of tanks today using the
link in the description
use code gi joe 21 and activate the
in-game missions to receive the free gi
joe tank emblem
as well as a t14 tank tier five five
hundred thousand credits and seven days
of a premium account hit the link in the
description to check it out
now back to the show now a quick recap
for those who haven't seen it and full
disclosure this film doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
antagonists and bird and science they
have it 10 it opens with the unnamed
protagonist taking part in a siege on an
opera house
while there he retrieves a loot box from
a duffel bag only to find himself
captured by the enemy being all
hardcore and stuff our hero takes a
suicide pill rather than snitch on his
team but instead of dying he wakes up
and is recruited into a mysterious group
with the dumbest secret handshake
all i have for you is a gesture
in combination with a word tenet after a
brief inexplicable stint at an offshore
wind farm the protagonist learns that
the future is sending weapons literally
backwards in time and it's his job to
find out why or
something to that end he teams up with
edward cullen to take down the man
importing these inverted weapons andre
sater but in order to get close to him
the protagonist must enlist the help of
sader's estranged wife
cat after he initially tricks satyr into
believing he's an armstraighter the
protagonist ends up helping satyr steal
the very same loot box but oh no this
loot box is basically an infinity stone
and now that seder has collected all of
them he can reverse the flow of time
entirely in effect
killing himself and ending the entire
world his death
activates the algorithm he dies the
world in to do that sater travels back
in time to his most happy memory but our
heroes are one step ahead of him while
cat stalls for time
they steal all the loot boxes then she
deals the finishing blow and in the end
the protagonist
learns that he actually goes on to found
the organization tenet and saving the
world was all part of his future self's
plan
the total operation is a temporal pencil
yours if you could follow all of that
congratulations
you're way smarter than i am it's your
head hanging but
baffling plot aside where does tenet
really go wrong
well we can point to the wonky editing
[Music]
enough business milo we think the
problem lies in the film structure
specifically
its first act now for those of you not
cutting your teeth as an underpaid
hollywood script reader
most blockbuster films including tennant
follow your typical three-act structure
i.e
a beginning middle and end in the first
act you learn about the characters their
world and their goals
in tenet the protagonist is recruited
into the titular organization
told about inverted weapons and tasked
with taking down the villain in the
second act you watch the heroes pursue
their goals
usually though things don't go smoothly
and they suffer a pretty big setback
halfway through the second dac
this is called the midpoint again tenet
mirrors the structure pretty closely the
protagonist cozies up to seder only to
accidentally help him steal the loot box
and oh yeah
cat gets shot according to the hollywood
formula heroes then spend the back half
of the second act
reacting to this new situation only to
have the rug seriously
ripped out from under them again a lot
of fitting into your life's pursuits
you're about to become a permanent
addition to this archaeological find
while the protagonist goes backwards in
time to save cat they have a new problem
to deal with
satyr is now able to end the world an
end of play can he be a little more
precise
everyone and everything has ever lived
destroyed
this launches you into the third act in
which the heroes have to overcome all
their problems and hopefully
save the day and yeah you know how that
goes with tenant
you've known me for years
[Music]
for me i think this is the end of a
beautiful friendship
but for me it's just the beginning let
me get up to some stuff
now if this all sounds stupidly vague or
overly prescriptive
that's because it is 3x structure isn't
the be-all end-all to film
many films deviate from such conventions
like pulp fiction to just about any
richard linklater work but
most are reasonably faithful to it
including some of nolan's greatest works
like the prestige and inception but
tenet differs from these two films in
one key regard
the first act whereas the first act of
inception and prestige set them up for
success the first active tenant
dooms the rest of the film to failure in
other words in order to understand
why the end of the film is so messy we
need to look at its beginning
take it from hollywood legend billy
wilder if you have a problem with the
third act the real
problem is in the first act so what goes
wrong in tenant's first act
brooks brothers won't cut it i'm
assuming i'm on a budget
okay not that to get anywhere near it i
would take a fresh face protagonist
my fresh as a daisy you know what i'm
just gonna tell you the first cardinal
sin antenna commits is not properly
setting up its main character in its
opening act according to screenwriting
guru robert mckee
a solidly written character does three
primary things
number one intrigues a character must
naturally hook a viewer we don't have to
necessarily
like them but we do want to know more
about them in the first
act of the prestige for example we are
immediately drawn to the character of
magician alfred gordon why because we
see bored witness the death of robert
angier a crime he's then unfairly
charged with i saw someone making their
way below
stage i followed him it was borderline
watching mr angie drown number two
convinces a well-written character must
convince the audience that they're not
fictional entities but rather a
real-life human being transposed onto
the screen
an inception we totally believe that
leonardo dicaprio's character cobb is
real
in large part because he has relatable
needs and weaknesses in the opening act
we watch cobb risk it all to get back to
his children all the while battling with
both grief and guilt surrounding his
dead wife
what are you doing here though
i think i found a way home it's a job
for some very
very powerful people people who i
believe
can fix my charges permanently
but i need your help number three
individualizes through a combination of
dialogue and action a character must
appear unique
on screen not just from other characters
but from anything we've ever seen before
on film in the prestige
borden is a brilliant and dedicated
magician and okay
maybe we've seen that before but borden
is also a man seemingly divided
i love you not today
what well some days it's not true and
today you don't mean it
maybe today you're you're more in love
with magic than me
and that's unique but while so many
characters of the nolan verse can hit
these marks on the first act this same
can't be said for tennant for example
it's hard to say what if anything
intrigues us about our main character
the protagonist sure the film opens with
him kicking some ass and attempting
suicide inviting us to question
what's going to happen next but this
line of questioning is short-lived
as we're told the character has
essentially become a blank slate
you don't work for us you're dead being
a blank slate it's then hard for the
hero to convince us he's real
in fact we never learn anything about
the hero's personal life
let alone his personal weaknesses or his
goals all we're told is that he needs to
stop some generic but suitably vague
doomsday
as i understand it we're trying to
prevent world war three
and oh yeah his beverage of choice okay
tonic
now diet coke
what you never drink on the job now the
film
tries to address this by presenting
sader's wife cat as a potential love
interest
but the whole thing feels patently
inorganic i mean seriously
does anyone believe these two wanna you
know quibby and get busy
i think we're having an affair don't
want to meet me
i'll have you killed let me worry about
that
did i look worried due to this lack of
specificity our hero fails to
individualize and differentiate himself
from the legion of other action stars
we've seen and yes
some of this seems intentional after all
nolan literally named his hero
the protagonist in the script so it's
fair to say that the character is to
some degree
intentionally a blank slate but while
other narratives like the cyberpunk
novel snow crash get away with a dude
named
hero protagonist as part of its
over-the-top satire we're not quite sure
if it's working out for nolan instead
we've got a character who speaks like
he's pulled from a generic
90s film i ain't easy fella we're
offering you buy me dinner first
but there's also a cumulative effect
that comes from not setting up the
characters in this first act
the action sequences begin to fall flat
you might think that the basis of a good
action scene is tight choreography or
mind-bending special effects
but you would be very very wrong it's a
bit like thinking that guac is the basis
of a good burrito
important sure but you kind of need a
tortilla first see more than anything a
good action scene should demonstrate and
develop
character the first act of inception for
example is rife with action scenes that
demonstrate this
cobbs for example ask small to sit on a
chair then using her as a weight repels
down the side of the building what are
you doing
just getting some fresh air stay where
you are mom
this scene tells us three things about
her character one that maul might
jeopardize cobb's mission
two that cobb trusts maul with his
safety in three that maul ultimately
doesn't care if she gets up and lets him
fall but it's not just
main characters like cobb that are
dramatized through the action and
inception even side characters like
saito shine when held at gunpoint with a
riotous crowd outside ready to tear them
apart we see saito turn the situation on
its head why now
which means i'm not lying on my carpet
in my apartment
you have lived up to your reputation mr
carr here
even the tensest moment teaches us a lot
about this character he's a level-headed
negotiator
and more importantly he's smart in sharp
contrast tenet fails to use its action
scenes to inform us about its characters
both in the first act and beyond
sure the opening scene at the opera
house shows us the protagonist is good
at shooting guns and kicking ass but
that's hardly an illuminating insight
into a psychology and you could argue
that we're cherry-picking here but even
the larger action sequences tell us
very little about the character just
look at the scene where the protagonist
first encounters the turnstile despite
literally fighting himself we learn
nothing about him
instead the whole encounter seems like
an excuse for nolan to use some neat
choreography
while this all might seem harmless it's
compounded by the time we get to the
finale
unlike inception when a gun is pointed
to a character's head we don't learn
anything
new about them no balls in my throat
character doesn't inform
action instead all we get is some
nonsensical speech
you barely understand but establishing
character isn't the only thing tenet
fails to do in its first
act the film's second major failure is
one of world building by which i mean
the way a movie establishes its setting
and explains the rules of its world now
normally this is something nolan excels
at consider inception at the three
minute mark the notoriously complex
movie states its central premise
clearly and succinctly an idea that is
fully formed fully understood that
sticks
right in there somewhere for someone
like you to steal
yes in the dream state your conscious
defenses are lowered and it makes your
thoughts
vulnerable to theft it's called
extraction in fact
inception's whole first act is dedicated
to explaining key concepts that will
play out in the second and third acts
we'll learn how pain and death work in a
dream state how you can have a dream
within a dream and finally how you can
plant an idea in someone's dreaming head
what do you want from us inception
tenant's first act on the other hand is
an infuriatingly cryptic affair in which
neither the conflict nor the rules are
ever made clear for starters we're never
told in the first act
what our protagonist is actually meant
to do or what's at stake if he fails
i thought i was here to find out what we
do rather we begin with
vague prognostications about a coming
war there's a cold war
cold as ice we even know
its true nature is to lose and by the
one hour mark we're still not really
sure
what the big bad seder is trying to do a
terrorist bomb even one that can kill
millions is nothing compared with what
can happen if you don't stop saving
from doing what we have been attacked by
the future
and in between anytime someone tries to
get more information
they hear stuff like this knowledge
divided my friend
other characters either respond with
pretentious non-sequiturs or they just
outright tell the protagonist that not
knowing is half the battle
ignorance is our ammunition but tenet
doesn't just play coy about the
protagonist's goals it's also equally
vague about the rules of the world
sure we're told about inverted items in
this fairly unenlightening explanation
one of these bullets is like us
traveling forwards through time
the other one's going backwards can you
tell which is which
but we don't learn about the loot boxes
the turn styles or what it's like to be
inverted until the second
and third acts in fact our hero only
learns that seder is after parts of the
algorithm not plutonium-241
in the second act and it's only in the
third act that we learned the algorithm
can end
the world as we know it now i know what
some of you nolan diehards might be
thinking there are multiple good reasons
why the protagonist isn't told about his
mission and the rules of inversion
straight off the bat
firstly any email or text message sent
today might be accessed by the bad guys
in the future
who might then tip off seder about your
plans emails credit cards texts
anything that goes into the record
speaks directly to the future secondly
because you're not sure who will betray
you in the future and what they might
know it's important to make sure that no
one person knows the full
plan again knowledge divided my friend
hear that sound
it's every screenwriter in the world
whispering irreverent
under their breath lastly and most
importantly because our characters
constantly go back in time
it's important that they don't use their
knowledge of what's to come to change
the past
what happens happened in other words
it's all a causal loop but while this
might make for a cool conversation over
bong rips and hot pockets
it doesn't make for an entertaining
movie at the end of the day there's a
reason why stories are generally told in
a linear fashion it's just plain easier
to relate to a character and invest in
their journey if we can follow the
internal logic of the plot
but tenet purposely makes everything as
vague as possible all in service of
trying to avoid creating any
plot holes or tipping its hand about
everything being one big
causal loop but instead of being
intriguing it all comes off as
variously generic inscrutable or just
plain stupid
i'm the protagonist of this operation
you
are a protagonist moreover you don't
need a causal loop for the film's ending
to be set up in its beginning
according to playwright screenwriter and
grumpy old man david mamet to have the
end
buried in the beginning is the utmost
accomplishment of drama
think about the prestige it starts by
explaining the rules of the world to the
audience recall the opening narration in
which michael kane's character cutter
lays out the three steps to any trick
the pledge where the magician shows you
an ordinary object
the turn where the magician turns that
object into something extraordinary and
the prestige where the magician turns
the object back to normal
importantly though during this
explanation cutter gives the audience
one key bit of information that will
unravel the central mystery of the film
how does alfred borden perform his trick
the disappearing man
now you're looking for the secret but
you won't find it
because of course you're not really
looking
you don't really want to know
i want to be fooled in short the film
tells us that the answer will be in
front of us the whole time
we just don't want to look and despite
the numerous clues in the first act we
fail to see the borden is an identical
twin
but where's his brother the reveal only
comes at the end of the film
after angier thinks the borden has been
executed in the final act we see the
prestige
the disappearing man reappears now we
think that nolan was trying to recreate
the same eureka moment and tenant with
the big reveal the protagonist
actually created tenant and recruited
edward cullen in the future let me get
out to some stuff
but this realization just doesn't feel
very satisfying largely because the
whole causal loop is achieved through
vague character motivations and poorly
explained world building about inversion
which
really is the problem with tennant in a
nutshell the film makes big sacrifices
in the first
act all in order to make the complex
story conceit
work and these shortcomings ultimately
doom the final act even if you
actually somehow understand what's going
on chances are you probably don't care
very much about the characters but
maybe we're being unkind here maybe the
only way to make a causal loop work in a
script is to do what nolan did with
tennant but what do you guys think
is tenet annoying and baffling or
secretly genius
did we totally miss the point yell at us
in the comments
big thanks to all our patrons for your
support punch that subscribe button like
you're the protagonist fighting himself
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
later
[Music]
does anyone believe these two want to
you know
apple plus and touch butts paramount
plus and be
parents with each other after having sex
hbo max and hit it from the backs